the WikiLeaks co founder Julian Assange
who's currently fighting extradition to
the US is facing fresh allegations from
the Department of Justice it now accuses
him of trying to recruit hackers to gain
access to classified information so
let's get more details now from our
correspondent in the UK sherry Edwards -
Lee
good afternoon tea just bring us up to
speed then on these latest developments
so another step closer to being sent to
the United States as new allegations
have now surface against him and they've
been outlined in an updated indictment
overnight so the WikiLeaks founder has
now been accused of providing a hit list
of targets as he has allegedly conspired
with hackers all around the world he is
said to have even tried to recruit
hackers at a conference in Europe and
one in Asia and allegedly worked with
online activist groups including
Anonymous in pursuit of this classified
information for the WikiLeaks website
now that's all according to the US
government who published this latest and
Dieteman
of course June Assad is wanted by the
United States but is currently in
custody here in the United Kingdom
battling against this extradition to
America which has indicted him under 17
counts under the Espionage Act and want
him to face trial the spying and
publishing these classified military
documents related to the war in
Afghanistan and the war in Iraq plus one
of conspiracy to hack a government
computer to publish these secret
documents now this latest indictment
does not add to this very very hefty
list list but does include new claims
against Assange between the years of
2009 and 2012 so the United States is
now describing this as one of the
largest compromises of classified
documents in history and if convicted in
America he could face up to 175 years in
prison now some people would argue that
his crime of whistleblowing is a
national security risk
but many campaigners say his extradition
proceedings should all be dropped
because there is no way that Assad will
receive a fair trial
over in the United States and in fact
they believe he's a valiant campaigner
the trauma Department of Justice attempt
to imprison Julian Assange for working
with his source to publish classified
documents that expose das war crimes is
the most severe us threat to press
freedom since 2016 that first thing
didn't work let's try another you
scumbags let the journalist have his
Liberty I wouldn dogged if the
department of justice decided to issue
the indictment just days before Julian's
next procedural hearing as part of an
AUSA smear campaign against him of
course students are washed out back into
the public eye in April last year when
he was forcibly removed from London's
Ecuadorian Embassy where he was seeking
political asylum from massive
two-and-a-half thousand days which is
almost seven years he then began serving
a 50 week sentence in the UK's Belmarsh
prison for skipping bail in 2012 but his
treatment since that point till now has
long been called into question and many
of his representatives argue of his
mistreatment and even to some extent his
torture while in our custody and found
much prison now Judith Sanders lawyer
says this latest allegation is yet
another glow to journalists worldwide in
an effort to stop journalists speaking
out the government's relentless pursuit
of Julian Assange poses a great threat
to journalists everywhere and to the
public's right to know well today's
superseding indictment is yet another
chapter in the US government effort to
persuade the public that his pursuit of
Julian Assange is based on something
other than his publication of news worth
the truthful information the indictment
continues to charge him with violating
the Espionage Act based on WikiLeaks
publications exposing were crimes
committed by the US government but on
top of all of this the United Kingdom
and the United States are abroad and yet
another extradition request it comes
after an Interpol red notice was issued
for the u.s. national and sakuni's who
is now wanted internationally for
killing 19-year old Harry Dunne he died
of course after crash in
Northamptonshire and stickerless who was
behind the wheel is accused of death by
dangerous driving
so the
two cases of a traditional position and
pitted against one another both those
seeking justice
you